ces jeunes québécois dont quatre qui
fréquentait le collège de maisonneuve à
montréal ont pris un aller simple pour
la turquie
un voyage qui pourraient les avoir mené
en syrie rejoindre les djihadistes
les deux femmes et quatre hommes sont
partis à la mi-janvier pas tous sur le
même vol
chacun a son histoire une jeune femme de
laval devait aller coucher chez des amis
elle ne s'y est jamais rendu ses parents
inquiets ont contacté les policiers
rapidement l'enquêté a été transférée à
la grc
un autre homme qui habitait montréal a
lui aussi disparu
son frère a alerté les policiers est ce
qu'ils se connaissaient qui les a
recrutés des questions sans réponse pour
le moment
mais ces éléments inquiète le
gouvernement fédéral qui reste cependant
avare de commentaires est ce que vous
êtes en mesure de confirmer qu'ils ont
quitté le pays pour se joindre grosso
n'est la question de notre sueur
opérationnel au collège de maisonneuve
c'est la consternation chez plusieurs
étudiants certains connaissaient les
disparus je le connais de loin un
comportement tranquille il pas de troc
pas une tranquillité morbide et une
tranquillité dans sa personne n'y parle
avec tout le monde
malheureusement c'est quelque chose qui
peut se passer n'importe où pas juste au
collège d'amazon
donc c'est très choquant c'est très
désolant c'est de savoir pied
on comprend pas ce qui se passe
nécessairement nos sources nous
indiquent que trois des six étudiants
gravitaient autour d'adil charkaoui cet
homme d'origine marocaine a été arrêté
en mai 2003 en vertu d'un certificat de
sécurité le gouvernement fédéral le
soupçonnait d'appartenir à un réseau
terroriste lié à al qaïda ce qu'il a
toujours nié
adil charkaoui louait jusqu'à tout
récemment des locaux au collège de
maisonneuve et au collège de rosemont
pour y donner des cours à la suite de
ces événements les liens ont été rompus
entre les collèges et le centre
communautaire islamique de l'est
qu'administre adil charkaoui le centre
clermont est mis sur youtube
denek un autre groupe de musulmans c'est
inacceptable pour nous et ça va à
l'encontre de nos politiques et de nos
règlements
karine tout ça suscite beaucoup de
questions mais c'est difficile d'avoir
des informations précises extrêmement
difficile d'avoir des informations aux
céline du côté de la gendarmerie royale
du canada n'a pas voulu faire de
commentaire le service de police de la
ville de montréal n'ont plus rien
d'officiel mais une chose est certaine
c'est que ça fait déjà plus d'un mois
qu'on n'a pas revu ses six québécois et
c'est très difficile pour les familles
certainement merci beaucoup karine au
revoir